- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo guys,
and over the last seven years,
Dan, I feel like we've been
rather confined
to the boundaries
of my back garden.
Yeah, not much room
for explosions.
You know, neighbors,
lots of noise.
Not the best.
Right. So we've been able to
convince YouTube to fly us both
out to L.A.
in order to pursue
some of our dream projects
for the next 12 weeks.
But to differentiate
from our usual videos,
and because we're obviously
very creative at naming things,
this is "The Super Slow Show."
( music playing )
Both: Whoa.
- Look at that ignition.
- Oh, wow.
Gav: For the next 12 weeks,
we'll be releasing
48 different videos
featuring some stunts...
( grunting )
- ( groaning )
- It looks almost too graphic
to show.
And slow motion we could never
pull off in our back garden.
That's ridiculous.
That's really cool, man.
Never believed in someone more
than I believe in Tony Hawk
in this moment.
( music playing )
- Yeah, you just stood
in mid-air.
- Just walking on air.
Dan:
You just stood in mid-air
with your hand out.
Because different subjects
require different speeds,
we have an absolute army
of Phantoms ready to go.
We got a new set.
We got a crew.
Here we got a slide.
New lab coats.
We got a green room
for celebrity guests.
We got a pool.
We've got a spinner.
- Whoa, geez!
- Oh, god!
Is that one of our heads?
Just rolled on the floor there.
Hold on.
We've got a dropper.
( grunts )
- Ooh.
- ( laughter )
More importantly,
new lab coats.
Oh, come on!
( "Ode To Joy" playing )
Oh, look at you.
Look at you.
( music playing )
( horn blaring )
It may look like
I'm inseminating a cow,
but it's actually
just salad prep.
( explosions )
Gav:
You look like you could be
an action hero.
I look like
an unathletic lab assistant.
Dan:
I look like a has-been
action hero
who's put on
a bit of weight.
( music playing )
Definitely something we couldn't
do in your back garden for sure.
Absolutely not.